is with us in Morgantown West Virginia
hey Alex how are you better than I
deserve what's up a year ago I got
divorced and since that time I've been
working really hard to do the Total
Money Makeover and I'm hammering down on
baby step two but I just found out the
home that my ex-husband got sole
responsibility for in the divorce is now
in foreclosure and my name is on it I'm
just trying to find out what I can do to
protect myself or if I should be
changing anything I'm doing towards that
situation Wow I'm sorry you got bad
legal advice because you you gave the
house away but you kept the mortgage
that happens a lot in the divorces they
just do a quitclaim deed and you give
over the ownership but you stayed on the
mortgage so you're getting ready to get
foreclosed on to is what this means
yeah I'm sorry how far behind is a do
you know about a hundred and fifty days
now okay about ten thousand dollars okay
and what is your household income I know
on my income makes thirty five thousand
a year I'm a first grade teacher okay
and his he had the house up for sale
trying to sell it on the market for sale
because part of the agreement was he had
to get my name off of city like off of
the mortgage and that was the only way
that he could do it but he's now moved
and so it's not a priority for him right
now so well he's getting ready to get
foreclosed on too so it should be a
priority to him okay well is the house
on the market with a real estate agent
it is it has been for about eight months
now okay what are they asking for
I think 290 now is what it's at what is
the mortgage balance 280 okay and what
kind of a loan is this FHA VA or
conventional and it's the benefit you
know he's the one who got the VA
benefits
so that's your problem all right there's
two problems that go with this and I
don't know that there's a whole lot
you're gonna be able to do about this
but the problem number one is is that
when the house foreclosures of course
and the time that it's been behind it's
damaging both is credit and your credit
because you're on the loan yeah the
second problem is the the foreclosure
will occur of course that's going to
continue that damage make it even worse
you will now have a foreclosure on your
credit report which means you're not
buying anything for four or five years
on a mortgage anyway okay
then the last problem is the biggest
problem I can deal with the bad credit
but the VA I will chase you to the ends
of the earth for the difference they'll
go after him first as the veteran but if
they sell this house for 250 and there's
two and an 80 oh they're gonna come
after you guys for that of the 30 mm-hmm
that's that's the deficit balance and
both of you are on the note and the VA
is relentless and so you'll have to deal
with them when they come to you I
wouldn't bother with them until they
come to you it's a slight possibility
they'll go after him and never bother
you but it's a fairly slight they're the
most aggressive of the mortgage types
for going after deficits and going after
the different bribe and you know the
differing balance versus what what they
sell it for versus what it what it but
that was odd right what is his income
the last say I was aware it was about
6070 thousand a year yeah well they're
more a lot of debt
they're more likely to come after him
and so really the only thing you could
do today is anything you can do with him
or the real estate agent to encourage
have they set the foreclosure date no
they said it could be anytime from June
on yeah of course that could be June to
the next June that just depends on how
diligent they are which a lot of times
they aren't so what I would encourage
you to do is do anything you can do with
him and the real estate agent to drop
the price and then when an offer comes
in that won't cover the mortgage that's
called a short sale and that offer would
be submitted to the VA and the VA would
have to approve that offer that would
get you out of them chasing you for the
deficit balance if you guys can get it
sold on a short sale prior to a
foreclosure now what you want to make
sure of before you agree to sign off on
this when the deal comes in is then that
the VA that the VA is acceptance of the
offer on short sale listen to this word
is without recourse and what that means
is they can't chase you for differences
if I'm you I'm gonna bother the real
estate agent I'm gonna bother your ex
and bother his attorney or have your
attorney bother his attorney because he
needs to get real worried about this
because they're gonna come after him for
a bunch of money and they really really
are Alex I mean I deal with this all the
time they really do come after you and
so I've done this is going to be in
contact with the mortgage company you
know myself just to see what our options
are but he is not contacting them or
responding to anything and you know
whenever I bring it up he won't discuss
it well it's from listen listen yeah
take your lawyer and spend 500 bucks and
Suez but then okay and get him get him
drug into court in front of the judge to
where he gets dadgum serious because
he's in contempt of court here by not
dealing with this and so this house
needs to be on the market on a short
sale you need to be bothering him and
bothering the realtor if you can't get
his attention then use your attorney and
the judge to smack some sense into this
idiot
because he's just walking away from this
is gonna kill him too
okay all right but you're attached at
the hip still is the problem with this
fool and so you're going to smack some
sense into him and if he can't get it by
you or the realtor your lawyer you're
talking to him then have the judge do it
in divorce court before this house slips
away because if you can spend a little
bit of money and a lot of bothering
somebody squeaky wheel gets the oil and
get and get this house sold on a short
sale it will save you a lot of pain
later you will not have a foreclosure in
your name short sells damaging to your
credit but it's not as much as a
foreclosure but the big thing is they
won't be coming after either one of you
for the deficit and that's by far your
best choice and it's worth some effort
on your part in his part to cause that
to happen now if none of that happens
and they foreclose well just ignore it
just ignore it and don't worry about it
until they call you and if they call you
just laugh and say I'm a first grade
teacher I make $35,000 a year good luck
I ain't got any money I'm not able to
give you guys anything you need to chase
your deadbeat veteran over there he's
the only one that's and pay anything
because he's got a much better job than
I've got making twice what I make and by
the way he's the veteran so go after him
and just laugh at them and just can't
and then someday you may have to
negotiate your part of the loan or the
deficit but that may be three four five
years before you have to deal with that
so if you can't get the house sold on a
short sale before foreclosure after that
I just get real quiet and just don't
don't have a bunch of conversations with
them and just let be hard to work with
and point them back at him and give him
his home address you know and just
continue to push that and turn them
loose on him because he's the one
dropped the ball on this obviously and
you know if both of you did everything
you can do and you can't get the house
sold then you did all you can do and all
you can do is all you can do you know
and you just you know after that you you
just again walk away from and
emotionally and deal with it when it
comes up at some point in the future
thanks for calling in so what's the
lesson for you listeners from that call
if you're going through a divorce or you
know someone that's going through a
divorce do not sign a quitclaim deed
don't give someone ownership in the
house I don't care what your attorney
says your attorneys an idiot if they're
telling you to do that because you're
still on the mortgage the only way you
sign that quitclaim deed is if they
refinance and get a new mortgage and get
your name off of it or the house gets
sold and the mortgage gets paid off but
don't you give somebody a house and keep
the mortgage people do that every day in
divorces it's common practice because
it's the easiest way but it's stupid
it'll get you caught into Alex's
situation
what a mess she's in bless her heart
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]